hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow season 7 episode 1 video we
got all kinds of stuff to talk about
they are going all over the timeline
just like the flash is this season
albeit in a slightly different way so
I'll explain how they're handling it
compared to the flash I'll also talk
about the black costumes Superman
picture Stephen Amell posted this
morning at the end of the video after
all this arrow stuff obviously careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet if you're new to the channel
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave an arrow
related comment on the video starting
with number 10 the episode opens up with
Felicity running through the woods with
William and it's a bit of a spin on the
way they open every single season
premiere if you go back and watch the
first episode from every single season
going back to season 1 the first shot is
always Oliver running through the woods
but I think what they're doing here
having diaz kill felicity and running
with William her screaming for Oliver is
that it's meant to be a nightmare that
Oliver is having because he can't save
them so he feels powerless in that way
so that's what he is worrying about 24/7
they explain later in the episode that
nobody has seen Diaz for five months but
obviously he showed up before the end of
the episode so he's back in town we'll
meet the longbow hunters pretty quickly
- number 9 montage of Oliver doing time
you just get a look for what the prison
is gonna be like all the different says
they're gonna have he'll be in there for
pretty much the entire first half of the
season right up into the crossover
episode so the reason why they
introduced that noob character the
person who idealizes Green Arrow is to
sort of give Oliver a big call to action
that you don't really see til the end of
the episode like he keeps brushing him
off but you meet all of his old friends
that he helped lock up brick Cody Rhodes
in bronze tiger it's been so long since
we've seen some of those people I don't
know how many episodes they're gonna be
in but I think they'll only be around
for a couple and we'll just meet other
people that are on Diaz's payroll inside
they're trying to go after Oliver number
eight Diggle comes in gives us our
explainer for where most of the
characters are they've split the team up
and because the FBI is still on their
case hardcore they can't be vigilantes
even though he gave Diggle that Green
Arrow cost him at the end of last season
he's not the new Green Arrow but
still has the resources of Argos so
there's sort of the de facto SpecOps
team when they're trying to take down
really big criminals in the city because
as they explain later crime has been on
the rise big time since Oliver was put
behind bars number seven we catch up
with Felicity at this coffee bar that
seems like it's actually a Dracula
reference is this 1991 Radu's coffee in
Raju was the younger brother of Vlad the
Impaler who was Dracula in the Keanu
Reeves Gary Oldman Dracula movie Bram
Stoker's Dracula was released in 1992 so
that's all I could pick out of that
reference but they could be referencing
something else but they just want to let
you know that she's been in WITSEC
that's what she's been doing as her
cover story I'm just a genius coffee
barista that can mysteriously fix
people's computers on the fly Black
Canary is the new police chief but you
get your first teaser for the mystery
Green Arrow person it early on because
of the way they pitched what was going
on with the Roy character I kind of
assumed it was gonna be him or Diggle
and within the first 15 minutes of the
episode they confirmed that it wasn't
Diggle so by default it had to be Roy
but I like the idea that Black Canary is
going to have to go after him later like
she actually is not really happy with
what's going on because the FBI is
putting so much heat on vigilantes
number six he saves Rene during the
weapons bye and then Rene sort of comes
around on him so it's kind of like that
are using Roy as their Punisher this
season where yeah he's kind of a hero
but he does really hardcore things that
puts him on the other side of the law so
it's sort of like Quentin in the first
couple of seasons like he doesn't hate
what the Green Arrow is doing but
because he's a vigilante it's against
the law he has to arrest him if given
the choice the William flashbacks are
actually really cool we didn't learn it
was William till the last one though but
the whole thing is is that he's going
back to LeAnn you to find Roy we'll talk
about what's going on in that future
timeline in a second because that's one
of the biggest WTF s number five
Oliver's super hardcore he lets break
and Cody beat the life out of that newb
but then obviously he has that big heart
like oh good thing there's a new Green
Arrow in the city because the old one is
a coward so that's sort of Oliver's big
call to action finally you have to
assume that their back-and-forth has
been taking place over the course of a
couple days so Oliver slowly comes
around on and by the end of the episode
like okay fine I will help him I'm not
going to be passive this whole time I
we'll fight back number four Black
Canary tries to lay that trap for the
new Green Arrow wild dog helps him
escape sort of putting him on the other
side of Dinah she does tell him later in
the episode if you do this again I will
have to arrest you but what that might
mean is is because there's no way that
they're gonna be able to sit on the
sidelines is that if Rene does go back
out he tries to adopt some other
disguise but I almost forgot to mention
to probably another big WTF is that
black siren is the new district attorney
because remember everybody still thinks
that she's Laurel from earth one and
because Laurel had worked in the DA's
office for so long she's actually
qualified for that job so I think we're
just assuming that black siren is a
really naturally intelligent person and
she spent the last five months studying
so that she could at least fake it a
little bit till she made it as the new
district attorney
maybe the writers are hoping we don't
poke too many holes in that but I think
she's on something of a Redemption arc
so she'll probably try to go after the
new Green Arrow aka Roy and any of the
old team arrow people when they're doing
vigilante stuff so even though she's not
quite as evil she's still kind of an
antagonist for the group maybe she'll
help them later in the season but number
three Diaz finally reappears at
Felicity's apartment to try and take her
down just so that Oliver will suffer
knowing that she's dead and they do try
to play it off for a little while but
you know that they're not gonna kill
Felicity up so she goes to visit Oliver
later she gives him the explainer about
William the hosen about how he's going
off to boarding school the hosen is
important because that's how we identify
William at the end of the episode when
he says he used to know my father
although I think by that time the fact
that he picked up the Robert Queen grave
and looked at it like they were trying
to visually foreshadow the reveal so you
probably knew who it was before he held
the hosen up I did like the Felicity and
I may seen that they gave her like she
does try to claw Diaz out like you know
there's no way that she could fight back
against him and he just flips her over
on that table usually you do not see
Felicity get action scenes like that
number two Oliver his big prison fight
at the end so he's been reading The
Count of Monte Cristo a book all about
someone who was wrongfully imprisoned
for a long long time then in exquisite
fashion exacts his revenge after he gets
out of prison
so obviously that's the writers
foreshadowing what's happening in the
second half of the season when he gets
out of prison and he goes after the
longbow hunters and Diaz but he also
literally uses the book to get revenge
by going all born on brick and then
takes the weight set and just takes the
rest of Diaz's men out the last couple
of big scenes are really important to
one we get the shot of new Green Arrow
aka Roy checking names off the list just
like Oliver during season 1 then we get
the shot of older William on Lian Yu
finally meeting him what are you doing
here you shouldn't have come you knew my
father and you see that Roy does have
you know bit of a gray beard the writers
explained that this is 20 years in the
future and the whole reason for the
flash-forwards are to show what Oliver's
legacy is and how the past will affect
the future is the exact same thing that
they're doing on the flash TV show with
Nora in cicadas characters so while
you're looking at him here William is in
his 30s Roy is in his 40s I'm assuming
that Felicity is alive somewhere out
there too because they have all the
smoke technology stuff that they're
teasing but when he says you used to
know my father it's past tense so it
makes it sound like Oliver is dead in
this future timeline the thing about
arrow though is is that they don't get
into a lot of literal time-travel with
people coming back from the future so I
don't know if we're gonna have a
situation where they go really sci-fi
with this or if we're just gonna see the
birth of something new in this whatever
post-apocalyptic timeline because the
way they set it up makes it seem like
things are really really bad in this 20
plus years so we'll just have to wait
and see how they handle these they said
that they would not have flash-forwards
in every single episode but it will be
fun to see what happens with future
William and future Roy to think about
the Superman picture that Stephen Amell
posted this morning makes it seem like
these are alternate universe versions of
the characters because both Oliver and
Barry are wearing biker boots so either
they joined a biker gang or this is
alternate earth we don't know exactly
which number it's going to be but
they're only a couple of reasons for
Tyler hoechlin Superman to be wearing a
black costume they'll be dropping more
behind the scenes for the next several
weeks
so I'll just include that stuff in
videos when they post it but this is
just one of the biggest things that they
posted so far new flash episode tomorrow
so I'll post my episode after it airs
and a New Avengers video should post
tomorrow morning a lot of big stuff
happening this week it'll be awesome
click here for my breakdown of the
for trailer synopsis and click here for
this week's new flash trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]